bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches je
vais vous faire part d'un secret le
royaume uni n'a pas disparu contre toute
attente
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ses
cages cela fera un an le 31 décembre
2021 que le royaume uni a quitté l'union
européenne
alors un an après le divorce comment se
porte l'économie britannique on va
tâcher de vous éclairer dans cette
émission avec vous olivier bonjour
bonjour refn et puis nous sommes aussi
avec pierre bentata maître de
conférences à l'université aix-marseille
bonjour et bienvenue dans ces caches on
va commencer à part un état des lieux de
l'économie de la grande-bretagne c'est
avec le tiroir cash d'antoine basse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un an après difficile de faire un
diagnostic économique du départ des
anglais de luge
car la pandémie fausse quelque peu le
résultat sur son sol après une récession
énorme en 2020 de près de 10% la plus
forte des pays du g7 en 2021 la grande
bretagne a vu arriver le rebond
économique au deuxième trimestre la
croissance était de 5,5 pour cent au
troisième elle a fortement ralenti pour
atteindre 1,3 pour cent cela
s'expliquerait en partie par une
difficultés rencontrées tout au long de
l'année les pénuries surtout de
personnel en particulier de chauffeurs
routiers
selon la fédération des transporteurs le
pays manque actuellement de 100 1000
conducteurs ceux qui causent donc des
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour des
produits alimentaires ou pour le
carburant et ralentissent la reprise
d'activité les pénuries de main d'oeuvre
ont également touché bon nombre d'autres
métiers et atteint des records dès la
moitié de 2021 avec près d'un million de
postes vacants la faute à la fois où cos
vide et au brésil qui aurait poussé bon
nombre de travailleurs étrangers souvent
européen à rentrer chez eux le brésil
aura néanmoins permis sur un plan
international au pays de trouver de
nouvelles alliances commerciales avec
israël tout récemment ou l'australie
vous rappelez le contrat des sous marins
perdus par la france au profit des usa
et du royaume-uni qu à côté de cela les
désaccords et les conflits avec le et
surtout la france ont continué de
s'accentuer
que ce soit sur la crise migratoire ou
la pêche par exemple reste également le
problème de l'irlande du nord qui a
gardé son accès au marché européen
ce que londres aimerait re négocier
tandis que bruxelles refuse
catégoriquement
bref un an après la grande bretagne
semble avoir pris plus que jamais ses
distances avec lui et eux même si son
économie
rencontre également de grosses
difficultés pour s'adapter
oui les premières réactions est ce qui a
été à 10 dans le tiroir cash en première
réaction c'est c'est ce que j'ai dit
dans ma phrase intro le royaume uni n'a
pas coulé alors que tout le monde
s'attendait à ce que ça soit à la fin du
monde ça ne l'est pas
il a des difficultés comme je dirais
comme tout le monde et
avec avec
d une politique qui est très différente
de celle qui est menée par la france en
tout cas dans le traitement du corps
vide et puis
mais ils ont ils ont des pénuries ils
ont du mal à
trouver des employés mais même si
j'essaie nous rappelle
non mais y a rien d'inquiétant et puis
ils sont en train de passer des
alliances évidemment avec un certain
nombre de pays
il se tourne résolument vers vers les
etats unis vers ce qui sont leurs alliés
de toujours un on nous avait dit qu'il y
aurait plus du tout d'entreprise qui
qu'il irait en royaume uni c'est faux il
ya beaucoup de sièges qui serait
installé aux états unis vous est vrai
une petite remarque sur les étudiants
puisqu'on parlait beaucoup d'erasmus et
des étudiants étrangers quand avant le
break site aujourd'hui ils ont battu le
record
d'inscriptions en université chez eux de
la part de d'étrangers donc vous voyez
que c'était pas vraiment la photo que
nous montrait les européistes convaincu
servent à la même question
je serai moins optimiste que olivier
mais c'est vrai que les résultats sont
beaucoup moins catastrophique que ce
qu'on nous avait annoncé on nous avait
vu de parler de récession de l'ordre de
10% d'effondrement des imports et les
exports quand on regarde les résultats
c'est pas le cas il ya une baisse mais
c'est pas aussi important et puis
surtout c'est ce qu'ils disent et
olivier d'un point de vue scientifique
c'est très difficile de savoir quelle
est la part de responsabilité du coc
vide et quelle est la part de
responsabilité du président parce que
nous quand on étudie un phénomène on
regarde un ce qui se passe avant un
événement est ce qui se passe après et
on compare par rapport à des pays qui
n'ont pas subi mais là comme le kobe de
touche tout le monde et qui part au même
moment que le breakbeat on a une vraie
difficulté à comparer alors les seules
choses dont à peu près sûr c'est qu'on
voit que le breakbeat a eu un impact en
termes des changes via une baisse des
imports et les exports qui est plus
importante avec les pays européens
qu'avec les autres pays partenaires de
l'angleterre dont il ya certainement eu
enfin du royaume uni donc il ya
certainement eu un effet par contre dans
quelle mesure ces
dans quelle mesure c'est quelque chose
qui à long terme va vraiment avoir un
impact sur l'économie c'est difficile à
dire ce qu'on voit par contre c'est que
oui c'est ce qui était dit d'ailleurs
dans le petit dans le petit reportage on
voit que l'angleterre et le royaume uni
sont en train de se réorienter vers les
pays du commonwealth en fait il ya eu
soixante huit accords de libre-échange
resigner donc bon peut être que le
breakbeat en fait les tourner vers vers
ailleurs mais l'impact n'est pas aussi
catastrophique que ce qu'on nous avait
prédit ça c'est sûr alors tout de même
des difficultés subsistent notamment
dans les relations qu'entretient le pays
avec la france on l'a vu tout récemment
avec ce drame dans la manche qui a
provoqué de nouvelles crispations entre
les deux pays quelques semaines avant
c'était le dossier de la pêche elle
l'est toujours d'ailleurs puisque le
bras de fer continue là aussi sur ce
point est ce que c'était des difficultés
qu'ils étaient à prévoir vivier
simplement quand on met des négociateurs
qui sont nuls il faut il faut il faut
s'attendre à un résultat qui est nul
c'est à dire que les négociateurs quand
ils ont négocié les accords de pêche par
exemple avec avec la grande bretagne ne
se sont pas aperçus que nous on avait
beaucoup de petits bateaux que ces
petits bateaux n'étaient pas forcément à
même de prouver qu'il pêchait dans les
eaux anglaises avant le break site et
que donc est donc en fait les anglais
respecte parfaitement l'accord qui a été
signé sauf qu'il fallait pas le signer
comme ça et là c'est une faute française
c'est pas une faute anglaise est
évidemment on a eu tous les toutes les
remarques et tous les discours monsieur
maquereau a montré ses muscles clément
boon a montré ses muscles s'il en a et
donc à ils sont repartis évidemment le
le le le front bas parce que ils sont
aperçus qu'ils avaient aucune
malheureusement pour eux aucune question
à poser les anglais ont
respecté le contrat qui avait été passé
sauf que nous on a signé un contrat qui
était mal mal négocié justement sur le
dossier de la pêche on le rappelle en
vertu de l'accord commercial entre
londres et bruxelles les pêcheurs
européens peuvent donc continuer à
pêcher dans les eaux britanniques à
condition de prouver qu'ils y pêcher
auparavant français et britanniques se
dispute sur les justificatifs à fournir
depuis le 1er janvier 2021 la france a
obtenu environ un millier de licences de
pêche dans les eaux britanniques et dans
les îles anglo normandes mais paris
réclame est davantage de ces de ses
licences pire bentata sur ce dossier la
pêche est ce que c'est un secteur qui
est si important est connu et
économiquement parlant pour le pays que
qu'il faille fin qu'il fallait continuer
sur ce bras de fer est ce que c'est si
important ça ou c'est juste une question
politique finalement non non c'est une
question qui est importante en fait on a
on a un problème globalement on a des
soucis avec la pêche dans quasiment
toutes les toutes les eaux et tous les
océans dans lequel on pêche et sur
quasiment toutes les ressources on sait
que c'est quelque chose d'important
parce que ça permet d'avoir quand même
un rayonnement une certaine influence ça
permet en fait d'être dans des dans des
eaux internationales et donc d'un point
de vue diplomatique d'avoir d'avoir des
accords mais on a des problèmes
quasiment équivalent avec le ton le thon
blanc au nord on a la pêche la pêche de
thon dans les terres australes et à
chaque fois la vraie difficulté c'est
que la réglementation économique sur la
pêcherie elle est très compliqué et très
souvent contre-productive on a en fixant
fait des quotas pour réguler un marché
pour protéger les ressources en question
mais on fixe des antériorités et parfois
c'est antériorité elles sont impossibles
à prouver il ya un moment où avant
c'était un peu le far west donc tout le
monde peut dire attendez moi j péché il
n'y avait pas de preuve et donc on se
retrouve dans des situations très
compliquées donc quand vous avez mal
anticipé qui allait avoir un conflit ou
un comportement opportuniste et qu'en
plus de sa très souvent quand vous avez
des petits métiers ou des petits bateaux
par rapport à des très gros navires il y
a une vraie difficulté d'abord de
s'organiser de prouver les choses on a
moins d'informations donc on se retrouve
régulièrement piéger comme ça pierre 27
à tous leurs vous évoquer l'impact à
long terme chorale briques site
la grande bretagne le bric si tu auras à
long terme un impact plus important que
la pandémie de kobe 19 sur l'économie
britannique c'est ce qu'estime le
président de l'organisme public de
prévisions budgétaires l'eau br son
président était interviewé par la bbc le
28 octobre dernier il a expliqué que la
sortie du royaume-uni de l'ue eux je
cite réduira le pib à long terme
d'environ 1 4% tandis que l'effet de la
pandémie le fera descendre de 2%
supplémentaires le niveau de vie des
britanniques sera lésé par une inflation
élevée des impôts en hausse et une
croissance en berne davantage miné par
le bric site que par la pandémie un mot
sur ses déclarations 1 or évidemment ça
fait peur parce qu'en plus ils nous
disent ça fait en moyenne 400 livres
perdues par an par personne sauf que
quand vous regarder dans le détail le
rapport ce chiffre de 2 4% de père du
pib il prend une hypothèse qui est qu'
il ya une baisse de 15% en import export
et que 15 % ça se traduit mécaniquement
par 4% se fait beaucoup d'hypothèses
c'est possible mais c'est pas du tout
certain surtout si un effet de
compensation si ce qui est perdu en
europe c'est gagner ailleurs et puis il
n'y a pas de lien mécanique entre une
baisse des du commerce extérieur et une
baisse du pib on sait que c'est lié
maintenant de dire que 15% égale 4 ça
c'est vraiment en prenant des des zips
livre il faut beaucoup d'hypothèses mais
rien n'est certain ce qui est sûr
j'aurais tendance à dire celle là il ya
un consensus c'est que quand vous êtes
moins ouverts vous avez moins de
croissance mais moi ouvert avec l'europe
ça veut pas dire moins ouvert un général
sortir de se sortir des traités
européens ça veut pas dire ne plus avoir
de commerce avec eux non plus donc ça
dépend vraiment de la façon dont
l'angleterre gère selon as le vrai
problème c'est le cas de l'irlande du
nord quelques comment ils vont gérer ça
ça ça peut avoir un impact en termes dé
change ça peut avoir un impact en termes
de capacité à commercer avec les
étrangers les américains nous le disent
déjà attention en fonction de ce que
vous faites les anglais parlent et les
britanniques il y aura aussi un impact
sur nos accords donc ça ça me paraît
plus important le reste c'est très
hypothétique pour l'instant
oui et puis
en attendant alors il nous annonce une
perte de 4 cents
livre de
[Musique]
salaire sauf que ils ont monté leur
salaire de 8 8% sur les salaires sur les
bas salaires et je vous rappelle que
nous on a monté de 0 5% le smic c'est ça
on est bien d'accord donc
voilà faut arrêter ce genre vous savez
ce genre d'exercice de prévisions il
faudrait que les gens aient un peu
d'humilité parce que ça ne fonctionne
jamais d'accord donc ne ne partons pas
là-dessus fin souvenez-vous dia dia
encore avant le break site souvenez-vous
de ce qu'on disait justement sur ce que
allait être l'économie britannique non
on nous annonçait fin à une quelque
chose d'épouvantable or
sanaryens d'épouvantables c'est une ils
subissent ce qu'on subit tous depuis
depuis des mois
ils ont eu des des reprises ils ont
signé des accords on l'a dit avec
d'autres pays et et je pense que
le le clown comme le disait monsieur
macron n'est pas forcément celui qu'il
pense mais si on va marquer une courte
pause on vient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ses cages si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine
l'économie à britannique un an après le
break 7 et pour en parler nous sommes
avec pierre bentata maître de
conférences à l'université aix marseille
parmi les difficultés auxquelles le
royaume uni doit faire face il ya en a
parlé les pénuries de main d'oeuvre par
exemple il manquerait au royaume uni
environ 100000 chauffeur routier selon
le bureau national des statistiques
mais aussi on en parle est une crise de
l'approvisionnement ainsi 9 millions de
britanniques n'ont pas pu accéder à des
produits alimentaires de base soit un
adulte sur six dans la capacité
d'acheter un produit alimentaire est
essentielle car bentata et le royaume
uni est est il réellement préparé aux
briques site et à ses conséquences vous
pouvez difficilement être préparé à tout
ce qui va se passer parce que en réalité
la difficulté c'est de savoir combien
vous allez perdre de temps comment vous
allez avoir des goulots d'étranglement
qui vont ceux fabriqués à partir du
moment où il ya à nouveau des contrôles
alors on a des témoignages d entreprise
qui fabrique des moteurs par exemple en
angleterre et qui nous disent remplir
avant un papier administratif pour
envoyer sur une chaîne de montage en
allemagne ça me prenait une journée
maintenant ça nous prend 5 donc
évidemment nécessairement vous avez
unique est une activité qui ralentit il
peut y avoir des contrôles aux douanes
qui n'existait pas avant donc tout ça
évidemment ça ralentit l'activité mais
c'est pas possible de prévoir l'impact
l'impact réel et c'est surtout très
difficile de savoir est ce que c'est que
du court terme est-ce que ça va se
régler ou est-ce que c'est du long terme
encore une fois ces goulots
d'étranglement qui existent ils sont
aussi présents dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui à cause de la pandémie donc
c'est très difficile de faire la part
des choses et de voir si l'angleterre
est vraiment touché ce qu'on voit
davantage et ce qui peut être plus
surprenant c'est qu'on s'attendait à ce
que les effets soient davantage dans des
secteurs industriels ou des secteurs
manufacturiers en réalité on a
l'impression que là où l'angleterre un
peu reculé c'est dans la capacité à
exporter des services on a une partie
des services financiers de conseils qui
sont aller davantage vers les pays bas
par exemple ou davantage vers
l'allemagne donc là il ya une sorte de
réallocation au niveau européen mais
je vois pas comment l'angleterre pouvait
enfin comment on peut dire le royaume
uni devrait se prépare aurait dû être
préparé davantage c'est pas possible de
prévoir la façon dont les chaînes
d'approvisionnement vont ralentir vont
devoir se réaliser surtout ne pouvait
pas prévoir la pandémie
sur ces problèmes de pénurie
d'approvisionnement comment est-ce que
on leur tire bentata bien le dire c'est
on sait pas si ça va durer mais comme
dans quelle voie pourrait s'engager à le
royaume uni pour port déjà on va on va
voir ce qui va se passer une fois que le
l'histoire
la gestion du coc vide aura un petit peu
évoluer vers quelque chose de plus
raisonnable c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
vous avez des pénuries vous avez des
2des des interruptions de production
parce qu' il manque une pièce ou une
autre simplement qui est dû à la
désorganisation qui a depuis l'histoire
que vides on l'a dit plusieurs fois
d'autres à d'autres moments ici en
disant quand vous avez le troisième port
de chine qui ferment parce que il ya
deux gars qui ont eu un test pcr positif
s'il voulait évidemment vous avez une
désorganisation puisque comme tout
aujourd'hui toute l'industrie est fait
en flux tendu zéro stock qu'est ce qui
se passe quand il manque une pièce vous
attendez et vous attendez le temps que l
soit libérée du du du port en question
où est donc évidemment vous avez des
retards évidemment vous avez une
désorganisation profonde et ça il faudra
d'abord y remédier ensuite eh ben on
verra ce qui reste comme comme goulots
d'étranglement et puis
je pense que les anglais ça et je fais
assez confiance aux anglais parce qu'ils
sont quand même assez assez rusé et il
arrive finalement à leurs fins très
souvent donc
donc je pense que ils trouveront une
solution et que lit pourront se passer
des conseils de monsieur macron un mois
sur la politique internationale avec ses
accords commerciaux conclus avec
l'australie plus récemment israël à
pierre bentata est-ce que avec ces
accords commerciaux avec ces pays la
grande bretagne peut surmonter la perte
ou en tout cas la réduction à de son
commerce avec l'ue eux sachant que les
échanges avec eux vous l'avez dit ont
chuté les exportations à vers le
continent ont diminué de 12% entre
juillet 2018 et juillet 2021 même
tendance pour les importations en baisse
de 13%
est-ce que ça suffit à surmonter cette
perte sur l'instant non de fait non mais
c'est normal vous avez géographiquement
c'est avec nous normalement c'est avec
l'europe qui devrait commercer bon il se
trouve que ça se passe mal il ya un
divorce et il se réoriente vers des
partenaires qui sont quand même des
partenaires historiques avec il est très
facile de communiquer parce qu'ils ont
globalement la même culture donc à moyen
terme très difficile de dire que ça
suffira pas à court terme c'est sûr que
non et c'est vrai que de ce point de vue
là économiquement c'est une bêtise ils
sont proches de nous il aurait dû rester
bon maintenant que c'est fait c'est fait
je peux pas vous garantir je peux enfin
je parierais pas en tout cas sur le fait
que leur commerce à moyen terme à
horizon 5 ans va vraiment diminué ou
qu'ils auront moins d'exportations avec
les états unis l'australie israël non ça
c'est un vrai défi pour les pays de
trouver ses nouveaux partenaires
commerciaux non je pense pas que ce soit
un vrai défi je pense que ce qui est
difficile c'est de cesser de remettre en
place un écosystème de de changer une
façon produire de de trouver de nouveaux
partenaires mais c'est pas un vrai défi
en tant que tel c'est quand même la
preuve d'ailleurs que ce pays fonctionne
c'est qu'il est très mondialisé et tout
et tout à l'heure si c'est les services
d'ailleurs qui qui qui on ont souffert
principalement c'est parce que c'est un
pays qui est très d'industrie et très
mondialisé et donc dans cette nouvelle
économie mondialisée les pays riches
font du service donc c'est pas très
étonnant que qu'il soit touché là dessus
mais c'est aussi beaucoup plus facile à
réallouer que de refabriquer des usines
pour acheter des racheter des plans anti
une production dans des endroits qui
connaissent pas donc je suis pas
pessimiste pour eux je pense qu' il
n'aurait pas fallu le faire mais
maintenant que c'est fait je crois pas
que ça non plus une catastrophe un mot à
olivier sur les marchés la fc as le
régulateur britannique instaurer de
nouvelles règles
à la bourse de londres vous allez les
voir en détail sur cette infographie des
règles qui devraient permettre d'attirer
plus d'introductions en bourse depuis le
début de l'année il y en a eu 56 au
london stock exchange c'est plus
d'introductions qu'en 2019 par exemple
avec elle la pandémie elle a su à rester
attractif finalement la bourse de
londres ou ailleurs est ce que là aussi
il ya certaines nuances à apporter là
aussi on nous avait annoncé la fin de la
bourse de londres et l'explosion de la
bourse française parce que figurez vous
que la bourse française à les remplacer
la bourse de londres non ben ça marche
pas comme ça et encore une fois on est
et on a tapé à côté donc la bourse de
londres est encore là et est là pour à
mon avis longtemps parce que
figurez-vous que moi qui ai travaillé en
bourse assez longtemps je vous le dis un
américain quand il veut passer des
ordres ils préfèrent les passer à
londres que les passer en france c'est
comme ça parce qu'ils parlent la même
langue parce que ça se passe beaucoup
mieux et parce que on est quand même
regarder comme des guignols gentil
lignol mais guignols quand même et donc
voilà donc lille ne serait pas étonnant
que dans quelques mois la situation se
soit complètement régulariser certaines
dates à je le vois à casser oui d'accord
noir ce que je trouve un peu triste pour
pour nous les français c'est que j'ai
quand même des pays comme en bénéficier
amsterdam par exemple à abe afin a
bénéficié de cette tension qu'il ya eu
en angleterre nous non donc c'est assez
là où jacquet c'est que c'est amusant
parce que historiquement en fait on
retrouve des coeurs économique en europe
qui qui en fait sont les mêmes ça n'a
pas bougé à amsterdam depuis le 18è ils
sont là londres et l'allemagne est plus
présent que nous de nous on ne bénéficie
même pas des erreurs ou des problèmes
qu'il peut y avoir dans les pays autour
on n'est pas un vrai coeur économique et
du coup on bénéficie pas directement
lorsque lorsqu'à ça parce que ça veut
dire que nos fondamentaux sont pas aussi
bons injuste la dernière question terme
à manhattan avant de se quitter deux
partenaires avant aujourd'hui est ce que
le royaume uni peut être considéré comme
un sérieux concurrent pour l'union
européenne
j'espère que j'espère que c'est pas
comme ça qu'on voit les choses parce que
c'est parce que déjà je comprendrais pas
du coup ce que vous voulez dire par
partenaires c'est être partenaire ça
veut dire être concurrents sur sur une
place économique pour travailler tous
ensemble et créer une émulation c'est ce
qui se passe encore maintenant on a
changé les termes du contrat mais je
vois pas pourquoi ça ferait de nous
maintenant des ennemis ou sa
transformerait complètement les
relations on est géographiquement
proches on est économiquement intégré
si on voit ça comme ça je pense que là
on va avoir des problèmes merci à
beaucoup pierre bentata d'avoir été
parmi nous et je rappelle que vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'université aix
marseille olivier noël on passe aux
questions et commentaires cash
on commence audigier avec le commentaire
de ces yagg la dette ne sera jamais
remboursé c'est là où olivier delamarche
se plante complètement
eh bien ils auraient mieux fait
d'écouter jusqu'au bout ce qu'on a dit
c'est à dire que
si la dette sera remboursée mais elle
sera remboursée pas forcément
par l'impôt ou pas forcément par une
[Musique]
taxation des
des ménages
mais vous avez d'autres façons de la
rembourser l'autre façon c'est soit un
défaut de crédit ce que je ne pense pas
soit vous avez l'hyperinflation
l'hyperinflation sa rembourse la dette
mais ça vous ruine aussi donc
sayag fait attention à ton argent
commentaire de farfadets des îles fait
aux riches et le japon c'est la preuve
que l'argent et l'économie sont des
instruments de contrôle social sur le
papier le japon est en déficit pourtant
dans le réel le pays n'a jamais cessé de
se développer c'est un paradoxe ah non
il se développe pas c'est à dire que
vous êtes vous êtes planté au même pib
depuis 30 ans donc on peut pas dire que
ça se développe à ils n'ont jamais
réussi à sortir de la déflation ils
n'ont jamais réussi à sortir de du nom
croissance depuis des années donc on
peut pas dire que ce soit brillant et
vous avez en plus le et c'est ça qui qui
drive je dirai tout vous avez en plus un
problème qui est le problème
démographique des japonais qui vont
perdre d'ici 2040 2050 qui vont perdre
un tiers de leur population c'est quand
même pas rien donc
évidemment ça va ça va jouer sur la
croissance potentielle parce que vous
aurez une croissance potentielle qui va
être de plus en plus faible avec 1
immobilier qui va probablement chuter
puisqu'il y aura 20 millions de
logements vides donc ça fait quand même
beaucoup et que et que donc vous allez
vous retrouver avec avec des des baisses
une poursuite de la déflation et je vous
dis n'arrive pas à en sortir puisqu'il
ne peuvent pas en sortir puisque leur
leurs mécanismes de faire de la dette et
de la rachetée par la banque centrale
qui est là depuis des années ils sont à
7 10 % de déficit budgétaire par an tous
les ans que qui est que vide pas que vie
d'excès tout ça c'est bon donc on monte
alors on est on était à 250% on va être
à 275 on va bientôt tutoyé les 3 100 %
sur la dette par rapport aux pays bas
alors personne ne s'inquiète un tout le
monde trouve ça très bien mais enfin en
attendant je vous dis ils n'ont pas de
croissance ils ont une poursuite de la
déflation ils ont un endettement qui est
maintenant gigantesque et dont il se
sortiront d'une manière ou d'une autre
mais de toute façon il ya quelqu'un qui
paye la note un monsieur sayag merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi prochain rendez
vous la semaine prochaine n'oubliez pas
de réagir à cette émission sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag rta cash
olivier on se quitte avec
c'est celui qui dit qui y est